well stuck in the emergency room hallway
that's what one local woman's ordeal
over at mountain view hospital mary jane
belliesa shares this patient's request
for answers and why covet may be to
blame
siobhan young says she arrived to
mountain view hospital sunday night due
to an infection in her leg since then
she's been waiting in the emergency room
hallway for a room and has yet to be
seen by a doctor
it's going on 30 40 hours and i'm in the
hallway i have no medication
they haven't i'm diabetic so my sugar
hasn't been checked
and i'm just i'm just here nobody's
telling me anything what's going on
young says it's hard to even ask for
assistance she says another patient
helped her use the restroom
i'm trying to get up to use the bathroom
i'm really weak i can barely walk
and the doctors and nurses are just
standing around and they just
watching me struggle basically dr
dominic martinello the chief medical
officer at mountain view medical center
says the pandemic has pushed hospitals
to their capacity creating a backlog of
patients with these big spikes and a lot
of people showing up and then right
after that all the deferred care starts
coming in so the people who were unable
to get treated in a timely manner young
says as much as she'd like to go to
another hospital she's unable to drive
or find other means of transportation i
feel like i'm forgot about honestly i
feel like i'm just thrown in a corner
and they completely forgot about me
we're hiring new people every day we're
getting creative with the way that we do
our jobs and we're putting in that
hundred and ten percent because at the
end of the day you know we want to take
care of ourselves but we also
desperately want to take care of these
patients mountain view hospital will be
expanding their emergency room this
includes adding in more beds dr
martinello says this expansion will
allow more staff to see more patients
faster reporting from cheyenne antinea
mayory jane vallieza live local now